i'll do my best to make this mean
something
he's laughing tom holland is definitely
a favorite in hollywood he's funny he's
charming he's witty he's british but he
can also do some super embarrassing
things
and we're taking a look at everything we
could find because we're evil
evil people tarantula daddy long legs
brown recluse black widow
number one imagine doing the walk of
shame in front of your heroes in
avengers endgame tom holland ruined that
big avengers assemble take the direction
was as soon as chris evans says assemble
everyone is supposed to yell and run
towards the enemy problem was tom
couldn't hear evan say assemble so he
went avengers and then i just went
and ran off by myself
he ran like 30 feet before realizing
he'd messed up and that's where that
walk of shame in front of all of his
childhood heroes came in like sorry guys
i got that wrong
number two what could be worse than
embarrassing yourself in front of your
childhood heroes try farting on your
girlfriend filming spider-man no way
home tom zendaya and jacob all had a
stunt together and we've all swung
together we did all swing together yeah
that's yeah that was interesting tom
holland farted on zendaya there was no
blaming it on jacob though because she
felt it i felt the rattle sorry about
that
that's my bad
number three elevator rides are awkward
enough with strangers let alone your
enemies in this spider-man no way home
deleted scene heroes and villains alike
share an elevator talk about weird and
awkward number four it's hard to imagine
a handsome guy like tom being
embarrassed of his chest tom holland was
nervous about his body specifically his
chest hair being shown on the big screen
for uncharted tom admitted i hope i
shaved my nipples on those days because
i have the most embarrassing chest hair
number five real pain is the most
authentic so of course the director
wanted it on camera while filming cherry
joe and anthony came to the car to give
tom a note and blood was just running
down his face he accidentally banged his
nose there was that conflicting thing
where both of them were like oh my god i
hope you're okay but this looks amazing
and they wanted him to just stay like
that for a few more takes number six
turns out peter parker has less control
over the webbing than they'd like you to
think luckily zendaya knows what she's
doing and she's got tom's back and is
front quite literally
whoa
let's save me mj maybe mj should have
been the one with the powers after all
number seven tom holland the clumsy
spider all we can think about when we
watch this is the poor crew who has to
come in and clean up after his mess he's
thinking it too we bet just look at the
guilt in his eyes
number eight did you know spiders make
sounds like cats
last time we checked tom you're playing
spider-man not catwoman you've been
rolling this
we just love that you can hear zendaya's
little laugh in the background we
figured she didn't even need to be on
set that day assuming she'd just filmed
her part completely separate
number nine recreating that iconic kiss
from the first spider-man but with a
twist did you hear tom got his younger
brother harry involved completely out of
spite tom was complaining about having a
long day at work when he hung upside
down the whole time and his brother told
him to suck it up because he gets to
play spider-man days later tom was asked
if harry would like a small role and tom
said sure but whatever you do make sure
it's an upside down stunt should we do
the kiss
excuse me
harry admitted it was awful and the best
part was harry's little cameo got cut
karma
number ten do you think the three
spiders were given any instructions for
what to do in their photo shoot while
doing the shoot for the spider-man promo
material the three spideys got up to
some goofy stuff like making sure to
recreate this meme in the process
doing a photo shoot with
two lads in lycra they definitely
developed a quick bond given within days
of meeting they were going to prom
together
number 11. most people are allergic to
dust or cat hair not tom i'm a virgin
[Music]
i'm so sorry
this was the moment when tom holland
realized he's allergic to virgins
i was trying so hard not just me more
like you were just waiting for the
perfect opportunity tom
number 12. the peter tingles come in the
form of giggles a lot tom can't keep a
straight face can you see my face
no not at all so i can smile yeah you
can smile just because you can smile
doesn't mean you should it's really just
not fair to jake gyllenhaal if you ask
us
you can't your whole body is moving
we wish we could be let in on the joke
what do you think is so funny the stark
glasses the costume if we don't shake
hands just do this
thank you
number 13 go brit or go home it took us
the longest time to emotionally process
that tom is british he's just such a
convincing american apparently not
always though like a grandmother
such a brit oh my god
like a grandmother like a grandmother
darling number 14. isn't it just like an
awkward teenager to unload all their
baggage right off the hop tom must have
been struggling on set this day it's a
lot of awkward improv for a kid at a
party honestly everything they said must
have been cringe yet totally appropriate
for the context but maybe not this one
they let you have parties you know my
parents
are dead
tom stay in character for all you know
you just wrecked the best line in the
whole series commit man commit
number 15. quit hitting yourself do you
think peter parker feels the peter
tingle when the pain is self-inflicted
you definitely overshot this one tom the
backpack is not done with you now he's
facing his worst enemy yet clothes what
are you doing here
just a little tied up at the moment
spidey
[Music]
back
spiders have great balance and so do
monkeys so what's your excuse tom
we wonder if peter parker's homemade
suit protects his head as well as the
one tony stark made for him
probably not
number 16 the set adjacent injury tom
was really good about not injuring
himself onset yeah
[Laughter]
my worst injury
didn't actually happen on set two days
to the end of filming spider-man after
they'd wrapped for the day and he was
just leaving he missed a step and slid
all the way down the stairs and injured
himself he didn't think much of it and
just did his best to work through the
pain his last couple days he went to the
doctor after filming rapt and it was
confirmed he tore his acl but of all the
ways he could injure his leg it was
doing normal people stuff it's almost
disappointing number 17 so much for
stark tech or the peter tingle
spider-man got socked in the noggin tom
admitted yeah i got punched in the face
i was supposed to dodge it and i just
didn't see it coming he had this massive
gauntlet in his hand a big metal fist
type thing and he punched me in the face
so hard like you wouldn't believe it
wasn't all the stunt man's fault though
tom had practiced the stunts without the
suit on but once he suited up he had no
cue for the punch as his vision is
partially blocked it makes for good
footage though and tom even said so
stating but it looks great i hope they
use it it's one of those things where
you stand up and you're angry like what
the hell man you punched me in the head
then you realize it's entirely your
fault we think it's completely fair to
be a little upset about a punch to the
head with a gauntlet though
how is it that all of these ridiculous
antics just make tom holland more
charming it isn't fair he toots on his
girlfriend and we're like wholesome
content have you ever done something
embarrassing while you were hanging out
with your partner we definitely have let
us know in the comments reassure tom he
isn't alone thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things